foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing some popular fan theories
pertaining to Severus Snape I'm going to
discuss five theories in total some good
and some band if you enjoyed this type
of video let me know by liking the video
and leaving a comment I've got five more
ready for a part two let's get started
why Snape never became data Professor
defense against the dark arts is a core
subject taught at Hogwarts that
purportedly teaches students how to
defend themselves against dark magic but
one thing that the position is perhaps
best known for is the curse placed upon
it by Tom Riddle after his application
had been denied the resulting curse
meant that for as long as the role
existed no Professor would be able to
hold a position for more than one school
year and Tom was true to his word as
after cursing the role each and every
Professor had their own unique reason
for leaving it there were many different
witches and wizards that acted as data
Professor during Harry's time at
Hogwarts but one wizard that always
wanted the position but never got it was
Snape Dumbledore respected Snape for the
most part and knew that he was more than
qualified for the role so why wouldn't
he have given Snape what he wanted well
the predominant theory states that
Dumbledore knew the role was cursed
Dumbledore knew that he wouldn't be able
to keep a data teacher for more than a
year and he knew that if he gave it to
Snape that something bad might happen to
him for these reasons he never allowed
Snape to become data Professor to
protect him Snape is a vampire we don't
see or hear about vampires too much in
the Harry Potter story but we do know
that they exist in the Harry Potter
Universe because Harry meets one named
sanguini in the Half-Blood Prince the
theory I'm about to introduce you to
suggests that there was one vampire in
the story that hits much closer to home
Severus Snape why is Snape a vampire
well his character just so happens to
possess many of the defining
characteristics of one the first major
characteristic of a vampire that I want
to touch on is avoiding sunlight it's
well known that vampires like some
animals avoid light they have a tendency
to inhabit dark conditions and some
spend their lives in permanent Darkness
this describes Snape to a t z nape's
office in the dungeons of Hogwarts is
described as follows the office was a
gloomy and dimly lit room found in the
school dungeons the shadowy walls were
lined with shells of large-class jars
filled with slimy revolting things such
as bits of animals and plants floating
in potions of varying colors Snape's
office is perhaps the darkest and
darriest of all of the officers
belonging to Hogwarts staff and the
dimly lit gloomy room in the dungeons of
the school seems like the perfect place
for one type of creature a vampire yes
we have seen Severus Snape under direct
sunlight in his Schoolboy days but you
can always become a vampire later in
life he could have also figured out a
way to spend time in sunlight as we know
that he's an incredibly talented Wizard
and an excellent potioneer the next
characteristic I want to discuss is
heightened sensors vampires are said to
have heightened Vision hearing and sense
of smell though I don't have too many
specific examples of Snape exhibiting
super heightened sensors he does seem to
have a habit of making an appearance
whenever students are breaking rules
wondering out of their common rooms when
they shouldn't be or meddling in matters
that do not relate to them I'm sure he's
always lurking around the castle at
night but he also seems to be
particularly aware of what's happening
at the castle at all times if you can
recall the night that Harry wandered
into the restricted section of the
library with his invisibility cloak
you'll remember that he bumped into
Snape and Quirrell even though Harry was
under the invisibility cloak an
extremely Advanced magical artifact
Snape still had a strong intuition that
someone was there this was shown by him
reaching into the air I think that this
is a reflection of his perhaps
heightened senses next up we have
morphing orb in the Harry Potter World
Transfiguration vampires are said to
have the ability to morph into another
form like a bat often behind the shroud
of a cloak after morphing they simply
disappear creating the illusion that
they have vanished flying away from
their aggressor on one occasion Snape
does exactly this in the Deathly Hallows
we see Snape jump from the Tower of the
Hogwarts Castle the following passage
depicts Snape flying in front of
McGonagall Harry and some of the
students he jumped said Professor
McGonagall you mean he's dead Harry
sprinted to the window no he's not dead
said McGonagall he seems to have learned
a few tricks from his master what this
passage suggests is that Snape flew away
JK Rowling is reported to have stated
that all wizards have the power of
flight innately but the vast vast
majority need a broom to achieve it in
Voldemort's case he was so focused and
Powerful that he was able to channel the
power to fly unsupported harnessing the
energy through himself rather than the
broom maybe Snape did the same but I
really think that he achieved it another
way a vampiric way going back to the
first passage where Snape jumps from the
Hogwarts Tower there's one line that
really piqued my interest I think that
it could shed some light on his method
of flying
Harry saw a huge bat-like shape flying
through the darkness as far as the books
are concerned when Voldemort uses
unsupported flight he maintains his
original form so what's this bat-like
shape why would Snape resemble a bat my
answer Snape's of Empire Snape's secret
message to Harry this theory is centered
around Severus Snape Harry Potter and
one of their first Encounters in Snape's
first year potions class it suggests
that Snape may have relayed a secret
message to Harry when they first met the
moment occurred right at the beginning
of the series in Harry Potter and the
Philosopher's Stone when Harry first
sits down in Snape's potions class
already suspicious of Snape Snape makes
it very clear right away that he doesn't
like Harry mocking him as Hogwarts new
celebrity right before quizzing him on
the spot about different magical herbs
in spite of his Fame Harry had known
nothing of The Wizarding World until
very recently and this meant that he had
no chance of being able to answer
Snape's questions this is something that
Snape undoubtedly knew hoping to make
Harry look foolish
Mr Potter our new celebrity tell me what
would I get if I added pounded root of
Asphodel to an infusion of wormwood if
you don't know well let's try again
where Mr Potter would you look if I
asked you to find me a Bazaar and what
is the difference between monkshood and
wolf Spain pity clearly Fame isn't
everything is it Mr Potter at first
glance all this dialogue shows us is
that Snape wants to bully Harry a bit
he's purposely asking Harry questions to
which he does not know the answer
however the theory that I want to
discuss suggests that Snape's questions
are actually relaying a secret message
to Harry however it's not a message that
he ever expected Harry to understand
Snape is a complex individual and the
message in question was simply for
himself let's dissect Snape's secret
message his first question to Harry is
what would I get if I added powdered
root of asphidel to an infusion of
wormwood and what's curious about this
is that according to the Victorian
flower language asphidel is actually a
type of Lily this Lily means my regrets
follow you to the grave in the second
part of Snape's question wormwood means
absence which is symbolized by sorrow
combined this could be interpreted as I
bitterly regret Lily's death and this is
of course significant because Lily is
Harry's mother the only woman that Snape
ever loved deep right to add to this
even further Snape's question even
contains an allusion to his own death as
asphidel was once believed to be a cure
for snake bites which of course Snape
eventually dies from morbum does he
Snape is alive why he never died we see
what we believe to be Snape dying in the
Deathly Hallows after Voldemort thinks
that he needs to kill Snape in order to
become the true owner of the Elder Wand
we of course later find out that Snape
died in vain as he was never the true
owner of the Elder Wand at all and was
unnecessarily killed by Voldemort
however what was always interesting
about Voldemort killing Snape was that
he didn't do it himself he used nikini
it cannot be any other way said
Voldemort I must Master the wand Severus
Master the wand and I master Potter at
last and Voldemort swiped the air with
the Elder Wand it did nothing to Snape
who for a split second seemed to think
he had been reprieved but then
Voldemort's intention became clear the
snake's cage was rolling through the air
and before Snape could do anything more
than yell it had encased him head and
shoulders and Voldemort spoke in parcel
tongue kill there was a terrible scream
Harry saw Snape's face losing the little
color it had left it whitened as his
black eyes widened as the snake's fangs
pierced his neck as he failed to push
the enchanted cage off himself as his
knees gave away and he fell to the floor
nagini killing Snape rather than
Voldemort using Avada Kedavra which
would surely end his life does actually
leave the door open little bit
particularly as it suppose nagini's
Venom that ends up bringing Snape to his
inevitable demise
Harry left the Silvery substance into it
with his wand when the flask was full to
the brim and Snape looked as though
there was no blood left in him his grip
on Harry's robes slackened look at me he
whispered the green eyes found the black
but after a second something in the
depths of the dark pair seemed to vanish
leaving them fixed blank and empty the
hand-holding Harry thodded to the floor
and Snape moved no more the above
passage suggests that Snape died but at
the beginning of the next chapter we
should take note of the fact that Harry
gets distracted almost immediately after
Snape's demise Harry remained kneeling
at Snape's side simply staring down at
him until quite suddenly a high cold
voice spoke so close to them that Harry
jumped on his feet the flask gripped
tightly in his hands thinking that
Voldemort had re-entered the room there
are a couple of things that support the
fact that Snape may not have actually
died
first of all Harry didn't really stick
around to make sure that Snape had died
it looked that way but this is a magical
world after all and I think that it's
definitely within the realm of
possibility for him to have survived
additionally Snape's corpse was never
found or mentioned after the battle of
Hogwarts all of the bodies were
accounted for even the bodies of Death
Eaters Harry sees the corpses of people
that he knows and loves Lupine Fred Etc
and provided that Harry knew of Snape
sacrifice it's reasonable to assume that
they would search for his body as well
Snape was bitten by nagini and
presumably died from snake's venom but
one glaringly obvious issue with this is
that Snape was a potions Master the
likelihood that Snape wouldn't know of
or carry an anti-venom is highly
unlikely particularly as he was playing
the dangerous role the spy in the
Wizarding War Snape was a smart man and
would have likely been prepared for any
eventual quality nagini biting him
included so how does that explain
Snape's lifeless body there's always the
possibility that the Venom only
paralyzed him and placed him into a
comatose state there's plenty of snake
venom out there that does just this and
this comatose state could have easily
been confused as Snape dying Harry never
really examined Snape after he died so
if Snape had taken an anti-venom before
being bitten it may have just taken some
time for the effects to kick in I don't
think that Snape bled out either as he'd
even invented his own counter curse that
could stop blood from flowing from the
body vulneros and in Tor another thing
that could potentially support the
argument that the Snape never died is
the fact that Harry never saw him in the
Forbidden Forest when Harry produces the
resurrection Stone he sees the shades of
his father Sirius Lupine and his mother
all of these people were massively
important in Harry's life the fact that
Snape wasn't there could it work either
for or against the argument that he
never died here's why first it's
important to note that the stone shows
you your loved ones and people who are
massively important to you given that at
this point Harry was aware of all the
sacrifices that Snape had made you'd
expect that he would show up along with
the other shades Snape protected Harry
for years and even died with the
ultimate goal of saving him so you'd
expect a sea Snape wouldn't you
the issue with this is that Snape is
just not on the same level as his
parents Sirius and Lupine Snape made
huge sacrifices for Harry yes but Harry
wasn't aware of them until very close to
the time that he presented the stone his
feelings for Snape were still settling
in as he had only recently had a change
of heart about the man who tormented him
for much of his youth Additionally the
stones meant to bring back the people
that Harry never got a chance to say
goodbye to and with Snape he did get
this opportunity
Felix felici's gone wrong Felix felices
or liquid luck is introduced to us in
the Half Blood Prince It's a potion that
put quite simply enables the consumer to
become successful in all of their
Endeavors Professor Horace Slughorn
potions master of Hogwarts once
expressed that he had taken liquid luck
twice in his life with each occasion
resulting in a perfect day a potion like
liquid luck certainly has an Allure to
it but it's also worth mentioning that
it's not very straightforward to brew I
have no doubt in my mind that over the
centuries many successful potioneers
have tried to brew the concoction and
failed one popular Snape Theory suggests
that all of Snape's hardships failing to
court Lily failing to become data
Professor being bullied and being blamed
for Dumbledore's death are all the
result of a liquid luck potion gone bad
during Snape's youth Snape was an avid
potioneer so there's no question that he
had tried to brew the potion it's also
highly likely that Snape had tried and
failed various methods as he had
instructions on how to brew the perfect
concoction in his own potions textbook I
imagine this took some trial and error
could it be that Snape drank a bad batch
and that's it for this video what do you
guys think of these theories if you
enjoyed the content please like the
video and subscribe to the channel until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to live
[Music]
oh